my name is Rob Vaughn rah and I'm in
Dava do not forget our names
my life would be
as we said before this is another sort
of off the cuff of sibling rivalry we
are actually going to get a set on the
next episode so we're gonna save it for
that one but like I said it's lame
miserably and we must talk about it
because miserable happy because
everybody's talking about it pretty much
Jean Valjean is on the run from Javert
trying to track him down all across the
French Revolution while also trying to
help Anne Hathaway MHI a French
revolutionary French Revolution well
what's that during the French Revolution
no the French Revolution happened years
earlier this is a student rebellion in
vain oh it the musical never bothers to
explain it what doesn't go into my
weenie - the first thing we have to talk
about I think it's almost unfair if we
don't is what our background with the
musical lame is Rob is yeah I know you
want to start that I I'm just gonna say
up front take anything I say with a
grain of salt cuz I don't think I was
the intended audience for this film I
didn't like lame as Robbie as a musical
to begin with to me it is like the
biggest sort of most bombastic eighties
cheese that you can find and that's fine
but if I'm gonna go for a these cheese
my guilty pleasure is phantom like I and
I admit that is a big giant chunk of
stinky 80s cheese but that's my guilty
poor boy yeah that's my guilty pleasure
my background I didn't grow up with
lamia's I actually found it pretty late
I found it through the concert DVDs and
I really liked I enjoyed it a lot
however even I have to admit there's
problems with it because the book is
about a few Bibles thick and you have a
musical that granted has an air mission
but you're constantly literally the
first ten minutes it's like this one guy
goes from a bum on the street to being
mayor no transition he's just mayor
there's a little girl that goes to being
a grown woman no transition it just
happened the man who makes antiphon no
attempt to fix any of that there is no
sense of the passage of time in this
film like years past just by magic it
just says ten years later boom
and like there's a scene at the end
where this is one of my problems hugh
jackman like it's supposed to be like 20
years have passed and hugh jackman
doesn't age at all he ends up looking
younger until the last 10 minutes of the
film when it doesn't give you any sense
of the passage of time and suddenly he's
got gray hair and looks ancient and I'm
like what the singing in this movie
which a lot of people I can just tell
you right now are not going to like and
the way I put it is that they're very
much singing the words not the music
this is not meant to sound pretty I
think maybe two or three people actually
get pretty voices in this aisle of the
grounds of a musical that's not meant to
sound good I made the mistake of buying
the soundtrack which is like 12 bucks
before seeing this movie huge mistake
the price of a tune if you are going to
see this movie to hear the pretty music
the beautiful music see the show do not
see this to hear the pretty music this
is meant to be dramatic it's meant to be
grisly it's meant to be sort of a
different kind of experience it was that
though in musicals before and a lot of
people I can tell you right now will not
like that I guess the best way I can
describe it is that if you could get
through gene Wilder singing in Willy
Wonka uh if you could hear him singing
if you want to view paradise and you
still got the emotional impact of that
and could see passes terrible singing
voice you'll probably get through this
okay but the difference is you only sang
once in that movie how many times is
Russell Crowe singing this well okay
okay okay let we will talk about
he-who-must-not-be-named yet eventually
I would make the argument that much like
the musical there is much wrong with
this film but I think the stuff that's
good is very good very genuine and kind
of a new way of doing some things that
surprisingly paid off I don't disagree
there's a decision to film the musical
live is brilliant and a number of the
songs where they basically just turned
the camera on and let the actors cuz I
don't think there's any real singers in
this movie but let the actors sing it
from beginning to end is really
brilliant and a lot of the cutting and
even some of the shaky cam and moments
is also really brilliant like more than
anything like I hate saying this I wish
this was how phantom was filmed as I
said that was my guilty pleasure and I
thought that film was a train wreck and
part of it is like the thing with
musicals I think a lot of directors
don't understand is you have to have
some sense of kinetic energy that if
you're going to film a musical you know
you've got music you've got dancing to
me the camera should be moving in such a
way that it really manages to capture
that and then the number of scenes it
does the problem is there's a number of
scenes where it completely is actually
totally distracting so it doesn't work a
hundred percent in my opinion it works
only fifty percent of the time but that
fifty percent is really really really
good but that other fifty percent is
really really really obnoxious so but I
I give them props for just experimenting
is like the director is on to something
this is how it should be done it just
needed a steadier hand it's like this is
a is a good first attempt it's a good
try it's like you you tried something
new and it's kind of halfway there and
maybe future directors can master this
system way better now if you heard Susan
Boyles sing the song you would say oh
wow that's pretty that's beautiful stuff
if you hear Anne Hathaway just the music
you're going to know what is up a bit
but when you see them - content format
the film and the performance it is so
heartbreaking that along okay I'm
actually completely ok with that
I thought work surprisingly the only is
a visual medium and it requires acting
stage is different and it drives me nuts
when Papert is like when just film the
stage reason because you're making a
damn movie and the movie works best when
it's actually working as a movie it
actually fails when it's just kind of
like shooting a musical or it just looks
like a bad stage production where it's
just like there's this incoherent battle
at the end of the film that's just shot
just haphazardly it's like they just
turned a camera on and you have random
angles no sense of space nothing and
it's just like how could you build a set
like this and not take advantage of that
as he played out the musical though I
loved it has a ton of problems like I
said with the pacing and this is
probably the toughest it's one of the
toughest books to turn into a musical
it's one the toughest musical
to turn into a movie for what we got I
think it's pretty damn impressive that
this turned out anywhere near as good as
it did but it doesn't work as a complete
film III think you said you could make
that argument I think it works better
than people are it works it works great
as a series of scenes like when I think
back was like that was a good scene that
was a good scene but by the end of the
movie I'm just like wow that was just so
jumbled like some scenes are shot so
expertly and other scenes are just so
incoherent it's like taking a look at
the Sistine Chapel and having like all
of Michelangelo's works together next to
Walt Disney and it's just like either
one of them is good in their own moments
but you can't put the two together and
you get so many long gorgeous takes and
then shaky-cam bits and there's no
in-between there's no attempt to bridge
the gap the entire film you have one of
two patterns you have a long drawn-out
take on an actor's face which alone I'm
like that's fine or you have these
gritty scenes of shaky-cam and just
random jumbled images which in their own
sort of scenes are fine it's when you
put the two together without any sort of
real establishing shots or linking
scenes at the cinematography just bombs
because when you walk out of here just
like you have trouble just kind of
remembering things because it was so
jumbled they should have made it two
films ah lame is Rob as a stage musical
barely works as a story because they had
to cram so much as but you work at all I
don't know but if I you have an
intermission you have an air mission
with this uh they literally have to cram
so much and still have emotional impact
to a point where you're right there's
not many establishing shot using a girl
I know not only you know the guy he's
gonna sing empty chairs undo tables
beautiful song but he's just there you
don't see him walking to the place you
don't see him looking at the visor that
he's just there no where's Noah yeah and
I turn it it has to be shot that way
because it's so damn much and I think it
should have been two films it Otakon get
three why couldn't this get one this is
why I told Doug when we walked out I was
like do you realize there were no
establishing - hardly any establishing
shots at hardly any linking shots where
you just have a tracking shot or any
shot where you have established the
characters in their location first
before they start doing something even
an establishing shot of the city
he goes to Paris at one point and it
just says outside the Paris walls we
don't get a shot of the city we get
nothing there was no sense of space or
passage of time in this moment oh
there's space it's just everyone's this
close
yeah it's everyone's this closer or my
favorite you want to see in this movie
and I know you're just like oh I adore
this cinematography adore this innit
ography what you know what watch this
tilt the camera like this like here's a
shot now I'm going to be singing see
this like ceiling up here that's all
you're looking at because that's the way
the shot is set up this wall and like
the one you have set up right now is
brilliant and you should get an Oscar
for it yeah well I'm sure he's got
nominated for Golden Globe Iowa it came
it said fish but there's breath yeah but
there's so many random shots like that
and I'm doing I would make some frames a
shot no I would make some arguments for
that and he did do the same thing in
King's Speech and John and II he did why
it does but they're more restrained and
they're not set against these much
longer takes they form a more coherent
visual narrative why would I
there's breaks in-between it all flows
this feels like a series of jump cuts
it's like you know this is the
difference you have like a narrative
that flows like a river like visually it
flows like a river everything seems to
fit this to me feels like a firework
show it's a series of jump cuts like
boom Dutch angle boom long take boom
here's a shot of a ceiling boom this guy
is you know like my other favorite trick
was you know he has like your scoot over
he has a knack he has an actor over here
looking this way and I'm just like what
are you looking at there's all this
negative space over it just doesn't
visually make first response to me did
that in the other films and I would
argue a little bit for it because
whenever those scenes pop up the
character is often confessing something
or going through something very
difficult or has to reveal a secret and
I think the shot visually does show that
because it is off-kilter it is awkward
it is strange I think it's very much
like a photograph a lot of photography
yeah but then you shot yeah but then
you're shot after that doesn't match
that then I will look at in the video
it's not focusing on that versus
focusing on the person in that shot
though so basically you just have two
random shots back-to-back
no random there's no visual language to
it is if you look at photography and the
way much of is being shot especially uh
you know I wants to travel in certain
direct but that's what makes it
uncomfortable that that's what makes it
awkward that's what makes it so much but
more it's also what makes it distracting
and there were scenes where I don't
think the point was to really be that
uncomfortable it just seemed like we've
just decided to put a shot here there's
one shot where it's in a chair just
talking to the boy and it's just angled
an extreme Dutch angle Ruthie no nothing
is far away like there just stay there
Dutch angles in this movie I thought
gradually very good like add like if you
can have to jab no if you compared to
John and stuff before if he actually
shows much more restraint with the Dutch
angles but there is this one shower
they're just standing in a room like
this looking at each other and it's
completely in it last two in at last
only possession is and then I go back to
completely stand like that was very
distract yeah there was one with that
that seemed crops up and Doug and I
simultaneously not even looking at each
other just went look at Matt and I I
would even argue that one of the other
elements to sort of make it bigger
because I understand the tight shots and
they it's supposed to be ugly and
everything but you know sort of like
what you said during the battles and
stuff you did need some big a few more
big sweeping shots there's one or two
one that's just showing the city or
Irwin Jabez looking out over these
anytime see not much the intimacy is
absolutely brilliant in the way he set
up a number of those shots
anytime he had to make it epic fail
epic fail um it just yet either relied
on CGI and really poorly done CGI yeah I
just it's almost a joke it's I've seen
video games like from 1998 with better
CGI or it just the camera just moves
around to such a degree that it's you
just can't tell what you're looking at
and again like John Adams I think works
because you can take breaks you can
watch these in little one hours snippets
I don't think people understand like
particularly this is my problem Peter
Jackson's The Hobbit you are for all
intents and purposes being held hostage
by a director for two hours 45
minutes so you have to tell a story in a
way that you're not going to a
completely alienate your audience and
that was my problem it's like you can
get away with it in one hour but at two
hours 45 minutes when you make it that
jumbled and incoherent another great
scene was um oh the master of the house
there's a bit there where there is some
insanely clever things going on with the
way he's pickpocketing you know
everybody but the camera is just like
it's jumbling everywhere and I'm trying
to laugh at some of these jokes and I
can't see half of what's going on it's
like shooting a Jackie Chan routine
Michael Bay style it's like why would
you do that you want to see the
choreography you want to see these slick
moves and the camera just has no sense
of where it wants to be pointing at to
basically convey the information it
needs to convey and and yet in some
scenes it does it flawlessly like the in
half and Hathaway song is fantastic some
of the Hugh Jackman songs you know and
there were some clever things even with
Russell Crowe I thought the idea of him
walking on the ED that was of that
building was ingenious so it's just such
a weird mishmash of just with that load
and random should we bring up E
who we now must name okay I'm only going
to say this I have no professional music
background so I will defer to the people
who do you are vocally trained what did
you think let me say this nobody in this
film sings pretty so I am NOT going to
attack Russell Crowe on the fact that
his voice sounds terrible because
everybody's does that's fine I am got
attacking for the same reason I attack
him and every other film he's ever done
in that he doesn't act and it comes out
in his singing you have Hugh Jackman
there say you know he just got through
pulling a ship in and he's getting his
freedom yes it means I'm free yeah
Russell Crowe there follow to the laughs
your itinerary this badge will show to
the day you die you're dangerous man I
mean it
literally actually yeah that's pretty
much carbon copy what I heard yeah I
mean and that was it it's actually that
may have been better than some of what I
heard now proves the true for 601 your
time is up and your paroles begun you
know what that means it's phenomenal how
much this guy doesn't give a damn about
acting or limpid desert if he does it
does never comes through the performance
um I I think I saw him in a Master and
Commander is the only film I ever saw
where I'd still convinced I was his evil
brother because he was like unbelievably
good in that but every other family but
he's ever been in I think he subscribes
to that Daniel Craig way of acting where
if I act like I don't care that'll get
everyone else caring and it doesn't I
get that other people not it's the
problem I never got that out of a
character I read arguments online that
was like well but that's the care I'm
like really because I would think of
you're going to spend your life chasing
somebody down for stealing a loaf of
bread that you had better damn well have
some obsessive-compulsive passion behind
that and that I did not get from this
character I got a more passion out of
Tommy Lee Jones playing essentially the
same character in the fugitive then I
did out of this like for me this is the
equivalent of like and against Hugh
Jackman who I remember the musical and I
don't think he's hitting some of those
notes oh no no no no no I'm not gonna
say his singing was perfect either but
his acting you know you could see much
like Anne Hathaway the acting showed
real passion when you put the two
together for me was like putting you
know would be like doing Star Trek to
the Wrath of Khan and instead of William
Shatner Ricardo Montalban you cast
William Shatner and live it right yes
even right you just like there's just no
passion there it's just very dead or you
know like William Hurt or somebody's
like you want somebody there who's just
gonna be like oh it's like I've been
hunting you all my life and when they
realize their life is a lie in a waist
and that they've been you know yeah now
supposed to be right huge moment and
you're just is going rapid up guy we
can't stay honestly when I saw the
decision he made I was like wow I mean I
I know the original story so I just
would have been like
okay hi hey it really didn't elicit much
of an emotion and there have been so
many good severe have been plenty bad
ones too but there's been so many good
ones and so many good actors out there
who can't sing anyway so this would have
been great and I'm just shocked that
they still went with him because uh I
never seen him actually emote yet like I
said with the exception master and
commander honestly his best acting
scenes and this is a problem I have with
the movie is that particularly I think
Hugh Jackman sing acts well I think his
acting is better and his singing in this
and that maybe because he's just been
doing film so much now he used to be
Broadway but the most authentic scenes
they had were the very few lines of
dialogue they had did you notice that
the two that came out of this room I
didn't completely unscathed was I think
Anne Hathaway and I would argue Samantha
barks who played the other love interest
in the third story is from late Nizar up
you know she's done the musical version
of this like tons of ties I mean she's
got this down like the back of her hand
but she also manages and Colm Wilkinson
dozens - who's also from the original is
that they both managed to sing their
part but they get the style as well they
know okay I have to speak this is more
about the performance that is making it
sound pretty and they adjust and they do
very well and it's those moments where
the film is the best when honestly it's
the long takes for all the the gritty
little shaky cam it's when I think of
all the greatest moments in the film
that I can remember it's Anne Hathaway
singing it's Samantha bark sing it's a
Hugh Jackman song where the image is
just on him like it anytime you deviated
from that pattern I don't really
remember much of anything I just
remember just flashes his stuff well
yeah and that's what he does that's what
the director does best and there are a
few shots that say like the mountains
saturated but they're very very finicky
okay so you just said early is the door
that's a pony - then John Adams I love
that but I just like wow that his way
does vast these long takes where it's
just in the face what no I I think it's
great I think he has a good mix but I
don't know but I'll agree and that is I
think what is mostly needed for Elaine
is Rob but at the same time there is a
battle and I agree
heed the broad white shots which there's
one or two but for something this long I
was so hyped from the opening cuz like
I'm like ooh yeah like it was a very
impressive shot yeah and then like I
never saw a shot like that again in the
entire film there's wanted to but
they're just it's like that one that's
supposed to tide you over for the rest
of your like here's France okay you're
never gonna see this shot again now
we're gonna be really tight on everybody
we put that but that's what it is it's
on the people it's supposed to be mostly
on the people I would argue that yes it
did me a few more but it's also
establishing shot two in the far I've
got 30 year long tails set against you
know a revolution in Paris and like you
need an epic cut and some of them was
after a while my eyes just glazed over
it was just so many random things just
thrown at you in jump cuts their
addition oh I don't think there was a
fade out or a fade in an entire damn
movie this is why there's a visual
language to film and you just can't do
that and I think the film would have
seemed faster ahead you actually added
seven minutes of extra footage of just
establishing shots or wider shots or
things to give you a sense of the
passage of time in the flow of time I I
would have been for that I think it
would have made it stronger um I think
if they did if they did expand this to
put in what it really needed and got rid
of Russell Crowe um I think we could
have had like one of the biggest holy
shit-fuck movies we've ever had and as
is in my opinion especially for what we
could have had it especially for what
they had to bring to the screen I still
think we got a good film like a pretty
that's pretty damn impressive but I'll
acknowledge there are problems too and
I'll also acknowledge that people who
enjoy the musical for how pretty it
sounds for how nice it sounds this is
not the film for you this is much more
than gritty this is much more the
dramatic I think you got a really noble
experiment with a lot of brilliant
moments but a failed experiment I think
if you're looking at this is you have to
make a coherent film the film was
incoherent it just was a jumbled mess
with spectacularly brilliant moments and
great ideas and you'll never be able to
take that away from him but it's like as
a finished movie
me like I honestly thought this was
worse than the Hobbit like just for
being like just sort of incomprehensible
like I kind of wish that Peter Jackson
would have directed somebody scenes I
was like man I want a sweeping you know
a sweeping shot over the city of Paris
or something or you know better handling
of some of these you know like Dutch
angle shots now let me ask you but
before we sign out here because you were
not a fan of the Broadway musical um I
got a better appreciation of the musical
when he did it right like more than I
ever had you know watching the stage
version or listening to the soundtrack
when the the intimate moments when he
did it right was way more affecting than
anything else I've seen them lame as Rob
when it comes to the musical so that's
my best compliment that I can make cuz
you know I still like the musical
because I'm just like how do you take
like that's my problem is it's such a
long story it's like taking the lord of
the rings' like we're gonna do a
two-hour musical it just if you don't
know anything about lame is Rob or
anything about the revolution the
student revolution in Paris is talking
about I don't know what the hell you're
gonna think of this cuz I'd be
completely lost the movie explains
nothing it cuts to characters to
revolutionary characters it mentions a
couple of historical facts gives you no
context you know time passes randomly
like I there was like an old couple
mirrors I don't have you heard them but
they were constantly her these aren't
guarantees no but I tried listening it
just like yeah what what did you follow
I was going on but no but it's a
legitimate point I'm just like it's like
you have to know the musical going into
this or the story to get it and again I
was not the audience for this film I
don't really like the original story
that much I'm Victor Hugo to me is one
of those authors that he has great ideas
for stories but if you try to sit and
read them and I am a fan of literature I
could read Shakespeare all day I can't
do Victor Hugo like I get like halfway
through it and I'm just like I'm done
like I'm out you know Hunchback of Notre
Dom great story I can't even do is so
take it with a grain of salt I don't
think I was the person this film was
made for but as a movie I think it's
just kind of messy
but with great moments take that for
what it's worth I'm too
Walker I'm due to run off and we'll see
you next time at sibling rivalry can you
hear the people sing I can't hear
anything after I sung that